good evening everyone
uh what an exciting day it has been
wonderful to see
nasa's rover perseverance successfully
landing on mars
as we celebrate human scientific and
technological achievement
let us not forget that we have the power
to transform
not just the outer world but our inner
worlds too
and that brings me to our distinguished
speaker and his talk today
before introducing mark brackett our
speaker for this evening
i first wanted to recognize the
generosity of mr and mrs
richard and barbara frankie whose
support has enabled us to bring you
these
great talks and discussions may i
request everyone to
mute uh please
i'm absolutely delighted to see that
they are here today
and i just wanted to formally remind you
that since we are recording this event
i would like to request all of you to
mute your videos
and we will have a brief q a following
the talk
and i would like you to kindly submit
your questions onto the chat
and uh dr ty camp will pass on your
questions and manage the q a
now to our speaker this evening it is my
absolute pleasure to introduce one of
our own colleagues
mark brackett uh mark is the founding
director
of the yale center for emotional
intelligence and a professor in the
child study center
and at the yale school of medicine his
research has focused on some of the very
very big
questions like the role of emotions and
emotional intelligence
in learning decision making creativity
relationship quality and mental health
and he's also thought a lot about the
measurement
of emotional intelligence and the
influences that emotional intelligence
training has on the health and
performance
particularly workplace performance and
climate
for adults as well as the importance of
this training
for young minds he has published
hundreds of scholarly articles has
awarded you know many many recipient of
many many awards
including the joseph zins award for his
research on social and emotional
learning
he also has an honorary doctorate from
manhattanville college
he's a distinguished scientist on the
national commission on social emotional
and academic development and on the
board of directors of the collaborative
for academic social and emotional
learning
so at this time while we are all
in this pandemic and worrying about our
sense of isolation
um i think a lot of his work will
resonate
and would be extremely useful and
enlightening for all of us he's the lead
developer
of rural ruler sorry a systemic
evidence-based approach to social and
emotional learning that has been adopted
by over 2 000 schools
preschool through high schools across
the united states and in many other
countries including australia china
england italy mexico and spain so
what is really interesting about ruler
is that it infuses social and emotional
learning
into what he refers to as the immune
system of schools by enhancing how
school administrators
lead how educators teach students learn
and families parents so
taking care of the full ecosystem of
integrating
this very important kind of intelligence
that has not been
recognized sufficiently or at least as
as important as it actually is
and research has shown that this ruler
boosts academic performance
decreases school problems like bullying
enriches classroom climates
and reduces teacher stress and burnout
so before further um
look i could go on and on mark is
extremely distinguished the work that he
has done
is so relevant and so timely and i am so
enthusiastic about it
that you know i could go on and on but
today
um he's going to be talking to us um
on his recent book called permission to
feel
unlocking the power of emotions to help
our kids ourselves and
our society which was released just a
couple of years ago
and um before i turn it over to him i
just wanted to mention
a couple of uh upcoming talks we have uh
the physicist and philosopher carlo
rovelli
speaking on february 26 and 27th
as part of a new series that we are
starting
on the nature understanding the nature
of inference so this is a new project
that um i've started as part of the
frankie program a multi-disciplinary
exploration
of the nature of inference and um
and then we have on march 1st susan
hockfield who will be speaking in the
distinguished
give us a distinguished speaker talk
at 4 pm as well and as you all know
susan hockfield is a former
provost of yale and emeritus president
of mit
so so please keep an eye out for our
mailings and join our mailing
list if you'd like personal um
intimation
of our events and um just
uh to close i wanted to mention that our
ongoing learning by doing
project uh is something that um
to solicit simple science experiments
for kids to do
so i invite all of you to consider
submitting ideas for this
and uh with that uh i would like to turn
it over to mark
mark welcome and thank you so much for
agreeing to give this uh this talk
thank you priya it's a pleasure to be
here um
welcome everybody um it's 4 15
eastern time on a thursday and you're
all
signed up to hear some guy from
connecticut talk about feelings
um i think that's a good thing right
um what do you think for you yeah i
think it's a fantastic thing it also
tells you
before everybody logged in um you were
sharing like some
big news that was actually kind of
fascinating do you mind just
sharing a little bit about that sure so
um nasa just landed a rover successfully
on the surface of mars it's called
perseverance and
it was a sort of a complicated maneuver
to actually
land it and so it's been a great success
it was
it is happening in real time we have not
yet gotten actual images but we know
that the landing was a success
and you know this is a very difficult
you know mars has been very very
difficult many countries
have tried to land and failed including
india a few years ago
so awesome well i was saying to
pre and team like i don't know if i can
beat that one my presentation today
but um i don't think there's a
competition between the inner world and
the outer world as i said
they're both equally important i
appreciate that thank you
i just need to be able to use my screen
someone can you enable me please
awesome thank you
all right you should be can you see yes
do you see the screen yeah right so
thank you for the introduction priya and
team
um i wanted to just start off by saying
that emotional intelligence has a
special place
at yale university um some of you know
uh that peter salovey the president of
yale was the founder
of the theory of emotional intelligence
back in 1990
he and my doctoral advisor jack mayer
wrote a theory that no one really heard
of
because when two academics write a
scholarly article
not a lot of people in the real world
read it but
i was one of the people who got a chance
to read it and so were
some other people and the term got
quite popularized in the mid 1990s
and once that happened the field
really took off in terms of measurement
in terms
of training in terms of thinking about
its application to schools and homes and
workplaces
and so what i'm going to share with you
today is a little bit about the work
that we do at the center for emotional
intelligence
that uh primarily focuses on education
context
and um so i'm excited to share that with
you
and i'm going to focus specifically um
priya
invited me to talk about my book called
permission to feel which is essentially
a summary of the 25 years of my running
around
uh the united states and other countries
trying to understand
why people are a little bit reluctant to
talk about their feelings and
what are the skills that help us to use
our emotions wisely
so here we go
i like to start with quotes and i think
that many of us
have been through multiple pandemics
we've experienced
the coronavirus for the last almost a
year
we've seen fires
burning homes in california and other
places
we have been made more aware of systemic
racism
both here at our own university uh in
the
in this country worldwide and the list
goes on i think in terms of
the traumas that many people have
experienced
and i call myself a chronic
kind of slight neurotic optimist and so
um i chose this quote for today and once
the storm is over
you won't remember how you made it
through how
you managed to survive you won't even be
sure whether the storm is really over
but one thing is certain when you come
out of the storm
it won't be the same person who walked
in
and that is by haruki murakami so i want
to make this interactive
and uh whoops and what i'd love to do is
just get people to share
when you think about that quote when you
see that quote
what does it make you think about if you
can all just get on your
interaction hats that would be great
yes please feel free to type in the chat
and we can read that out
um so there's a comment from simone
uh who says i can get to really be
present
um makes her aware of the present
uh we have a request to put the quote
back up again
of course i thought it was still there
sorry
elizabeth points out that we become
fundamentally changed by our experiences
and chris refers to the suffering in
texas right now
and haddad talks about learning more
about herself
strengths and weaknesses
and uh john um donatic mentions that
the belief that the self is adaptable
and ever-changing
yes a couple of people have um echoed
that
feeling thank you priya
one of the things that i want to share
that i learned over the last 10 months
uh is around gratitude uh
oftentimes we think of gratitude like
it's a bit cliche these days right we're
told
to write a gratitude journal or say
we're told you know you should be
grateful
and certainly um it's important
but what i was surprised by in a study
that i ran over the summer i was just i
did a study by myself i was just really
curious and i ran it
with about a thousand participants and i
asked people across the united states
to describe the things for which they're
grateful and what we found in the study
was that
people said my family my finances my
security
that i have food all kind of the basics
that you might think of
but one thing that stood out to me as
not being present
on people's lists was things like
grocery store clerks the nurses and
doctors that are putting their lives at
risk the teachers who are suffering
you know in terms of working from home
and having it or go to school and put
themselves at risk
and so for me one of my takeaways you
know from the pandemic is just about
gratitude you know when i go now grocery
shopping i
see a nurse or a doctor when i see a
first responder when i see someone who's
delivering a package
i just think about my goodness you know
i have the privilege to work from home
and
and i have that safety uh whereas many
people don't
and i think all of us have learned
something from this pandemic for sure
that was just my my one takeaway
now this talk is about emotional
intelligence and
i would be doing a weird job if i didn't
ask you how you were feeling
so at the center for emotional
intelligence we use a tool we call the
mood meter
and it's based in science that um
essentially asserts that how we feel is
a product of two core dimensions of
what's called affect
our appraisal and our
arousal or our activation levels so on
the x-axis it asks you to think about
your pleasantness right now
from -5 like this is the worst
experience of my life
to plus five oh my goodness i'm taking
an
hour out of my day to just sit and think
about emotion
so just take a moment and think about
where you're at on pleasantness
on the y-axis it says the word energy
literally
think about your physiology right now do
you feel like
your body isn't is well rested and that
you've got lots of energy
or do you feel like you just want to
jump into bed and pull the covers of
your head
so what's your body telling you right
now energized or depleted
then we cross our two axes to create our
medidor emotional
our mood meter yellow red blue and green
so take a moment
and think about what color are you in
today can everyone please do that
let's go into our chat box and just
what's the color that represents your
current emotion state
yellows green we have a lot of yellows
tiny ones you can share it if you like
yeah sure we see a lot of yellows some
greens we have a blue
orange yellow
some pre as a yellow
and a bunch more greens mostly green and
yellow i'd say
cool so
maybe that's this is like a special day
because the research that i've done over
the last couple of months would not
indicate
that uh there are a lot of people in the
yellow and green but
i'm gonna take what i can get today what
i'd like you to do right now is convert
your color to a specific feeling word
what would be the exact word that you
would use to describe how you're feeling
right now
ready you have three seconds to write
that word three two
one curious relax content
peaceful tired thrilled okay mellow
hopeful okay
silly irritated curious
hopeful
just give me a yes or no in the chat box
quickly how many of you found
it a little difficult to go from the
broad quadrant
to like that specific word
so mostly yeses any hypotheses around
that
i mean what might be the reason
that it is moderately difficult
to articulate words are not specific
enough
cognitive dissonance feeling more than
one thing
not easy to name our feelings not used
to practicing it
lack of vocabulary there are fewer words
in squares
nico there are over 2000 words actually
in a new study that we ran
we found 16 000 words feeling words
but most of us use what too fine okay
whatever
here's your cheat sheet by the way so uh
this is on the inside cover
of my book it's the mood meter with the
words we give you the first hundred
um as a as a practice you know to just
build that vocabulary that basic
vocabulary
you can see here there are nuances in
terms of
building that self-awareness that
emotion language
now what i'd like you to do for the next
minute or so is take a moment and think
about the strategy
that you think is going to best serve
you to get the most out of today so many
of you said you were in the yellow and
green
and my question for you is what might be
the strategy that would help you stay
there
because probably being in the deep red
if you were enraged or having
you know feelings of panic you probably
would have difficulty concentrating
if you're in the deep blue you might be
worrying or thinking about
you know the support you need
which is okay but not the best for
learning
so what might be your strategy
where does curious learner mode live i
think that's kind of motivated focused
engaged what do you think laura
you're going to be open pay attention
how many of you if you have children
who've had like
complete kind of meltdowns during the
pandemic um when your kid is having a
meltdown you say come on honey
just be open or come on just pay
attention
cristal is away from the kids so that's
your strategy just is giving yourself
some space away from the kids
other strategies
breathe listen same thing are you going
to just tell your kids just breathe
just listen happiness is a choice
focus these are it's tough
let me get a raise of hands everyone
know how to raise their hands in uh zoom
give me a quick raise of hands if over
the last nine months
you have struggled at some point or
another with regulating your own
feelings
okay a lot of people
let me ask you another question how many
of you have struggled
raise your hands again with
dealing with other people's feelings
okay so we're all in the same boat
pretty much
what our research shows at the center is
the following that a lot of people are
experiencing some pretty intense
emotions right now
from over the nine last nine months i
think we studied well over thirty
thousand people
and what we found continuously is
anxiety
is the number one emotion that people
report feeling
when we ask them how do you want to feel
we find very different emotions during
different times
so over the summer for example we asked
a couple thousand teachers and they said
we want to be excited
and then we asked them in the fall and
they said no forget about excitement we
just want to be appreciated and
valued and supported and so
what we have here are interesting
phenomena we've got our
emotion state the one that we're feeling
and then we have our what we might call
ideal affect or our hope for emotion
state
and oftentimes there's a big discrepancy
between the two
and so that leads us to think about
what's the goal here
is the goal to go from that red and blue
and just be in the yellow and green
what do you think i would ask you what
is the goal like what are we supposed to
do
with all of our feelings what would you
say
what would you say
share and be patient accept them don't
get stuck in anyone feeling share in
order to grow
recognize and be aware understand them
accept them
i think i think all of you are doing
pretty well here
strifer has but remember the weather
changes
okay well one thing that i want to get
to today
is that there's there's a there's a
difficult challenge we have with this
idea of striving for happiness
um you know we're you know the founding
documents of our country right are the
pers
you know report that we have to pursue
happiness
a colleague who was here at yale june
gruber who used to study uh sick we used
to do some research together
um did some research on the dark side of
happiness that when we
strive daily like we have this kind of
goal to be happy all the time it can
lead to a lot of
disappointment um think about that
you're bound to be disappointed if every
day you're trying to be happy i don't
know about you but like that's
really hard for me anyone relate to that
that this striving for happiness can
actually backfire
does that resonate
and so maybe we need to think about it a
little differently
yeah actually just did an hour and a
half uh session today
uh with this group on toxic positivity
this idea of like always having to show
up being happy and on
and you can imagine when you're a boss
or a parent uh or a teacher always
like demonstrating that you're in a good
mood or feeling optimistic and positive
how that might just rub people the wrong
way
but it also what does that do as a for
the children that we are
raising and teaching it makes them think
like the only emotion that matters is
happiness which
probably is not what we want
so the vision of the center for
emotional intelligence is to use the
power of emotions to create a healthier
and more innovative
and compassionate society
i argue in my most recent book that it
starts with ourselves
and giving everyone else this concept
of permission to feel and i think a lot
of you actually when i asked you about
what the goal is
you intuitively got to this point
so here i am asking you right now
and whatever role you have in life a
student
a mom a dad a professor multiple you can
be
all those roles when you think about the
concept
of permission to feel what does it make
you think about
and just take a moment and jot down your
ideas
vulnerability free will
permission to stop failing sometimes not
being lawyerly
i actually did a talk for the general
counsel's office here years ago and one
lawyer said to me
there's no feelings in law
let go of our emotions being human no
need to have to explain yourself all the
time vulnerability
how many of you feel that in your
current role
that you have the freedom
to be your true full feeling self
how many of you feel like there are
times when actually you need to
kind of fake it or you you can't
actually express
your honest feelings
so many of us right because
these concepts don't live only within us
as individuals
these are concepts that live in homes
and schools
in workplaces and communities and so
one of the other things that we have to
think about is do we have a permission
to feel culture and climate in our home
schools and workplaces
now i've asked a lot of people and
you're right
uh clara it depends on the situation and
the emotion
so over the last year um i've done
i don't know a couple hundred
presentations a couple years and i've
asked
literally tens of thousands of people
have compiled the data
when you think of this permission to
feel what are the characteristics
what we find is that people say
compassionate empathic non-judgmental
supportive
unconditional love patient supportive
so i wonder a how many of you are
these things for yourself right now
self-compassionate being vulnerable even
with yourself showing self-care and
empathy
being non-judgmental of your own
feelings how many of you feel like
you know something i could use some work
in this area
anyone feel like they could do some work
and how about with other people
especially when you're experiencing
strong unpleasant feelings
it's hard to be compassionate empathic
non-judgmental is awarded when you're
activated isn't it
now what i want to jump to is
the science around this so we know from
interviewing people that there are
multiple components of giving oneself
permission to feel but we're at yale
university and
you know i've done my share of
presentations in different departments
and i must say that some people you know
they're like enough you know mark we you
know
we like your stories we like the
anecdotes but you know
what's the science and you know as priya
told you
we you know we don't just talk about
these things we do rigorous research and
i oftentimes tell people
and i think this is the danger in a lot
of our fields especially in applied
psychology
is that people always ask me so mark
what's your opinion about something
and i always tell people like you know
i'm
fine you know sharing my opinion but
what you really want to know is
what is the science behind what i'm
speaking about
so when i talk about emotion regulation
it's not what
matters is my opinion what matters is
what the data show or the science shows
in terms of what works for people
in supporting them and managing their
feelings and so i think what's most
important for all of you to understand
is a
we should be blessed that we have a
president at yale who
took all of the kind of science from the
1930s and 40s and 50s and 60s and 70s
and 80s
and compiled it into a comprehensive
theory and made it public
that there is a way to be smart about
our feelings that emotions are
not disruptive their information
and that they matter for five really
important reasons
the first is attention memory learning
think about it
if you're bored right now with my
presentation
you're doing something else you're not
paying attention because your emotions
are driving
your attentional capacity my friend mary
helen immordina yang she's a
neuroscientist she goes
we learn what we care about
which means that this is also a
relational
experience like i am in many ways
co-regulating
your experience right now because if i
talk like this for an hour
and i just said emotions matter and i
just had a really like
kind of bored facial expression and
really monotone voice
how many of you would log off
somebody's laughing behind the scenes
right you'd be like you may you may stay
on out of respect
for whatever bizarre reason but you
would be like oh my goodness i can't
take it when i'm going to lose it has
anyone ever had a class like that where
you're
like you're the content is something
you're passionate about
but the presentation is like
has anyone ever had that it's like it's
painful isn't it
and so what this tells us is that
emotions are
what they're relational experiences
decision making
how we feel influences the choices we
make relationship
quality we say in our center that
emotions are signals to approach or
avoid
has anyone here ever worked with someone
or lived with someone who is very
difficult
like just difficult to be with
and how many of you when you worked for
that person or live with that person
would say to yourself
gosh i can't wait to spend more time
with them today
[Music]
no you wake up and then when you're like
oh i can't believe i have to deal with
this
oh i have to say hello or at work you
look at them you're like i'm gonna go
the other way
because again think about this
co-regulatory process
we look at other people's facial
expressions we have memories of the way
they've treated us
and they create activation levels within
us
physical and mental health
one of the studies we did showed that
literally
how we feel in terms of the culture and
climate of our organization influences
our
own stress levels which influences our
physical health like
sleep problems our body mass index which
is
an indicator of body fat and then
finally performance and creativity
one of our scientists her name is zorana
she studies
the link between emotions and creativity
and she says emotions are the
fuel to creativity
but it's our emotional intelligence that
helps us
make that creative process an actual
product
and this always reminds me of being a
professor here at yale where all of my
students have
amazing grade point averages and they
all have
high test scores sat scores gres for
graduate school
and then you would think well okay if
academic ability
is the driver of success and everyone
here should end up being highly
successful
because the range is so tight
but it's the exact reason why that
doesn't matter when you have a
restriction of range of a construct
it can no longer predict outcome so like
basketball
everyone who is on a basketball team i
mean from what i gather
is really tall like i don't think i'm
five foot eight in like eight and a
quarter
so like they're not picking me to be on
any basketball team
um i can't even you know i'm not going
to get into that but
so height right no longer really is a
predictor of success in basketball
just like at yale iq
greek gpa test scores is no longer a
predictive
um variable does this resonate with
people that means there has to be other
things
other attributes of who we are that
contribute to our success
and what i'm arguing of course and have
the evidence for is that
a big part of that is our emotional
intelligence
so my question for all of you is do you
see yourself as an emotional scientist
or an emotion judge
are you curious are you an explorer
are you reflective do you want to get
specific or
do you see yourself as more of like you
know what
i don't really talk about feelings they
kind of like they get in the way
i had a teacher last year say to me you
know i check my emotions
at the door emotions have no i have to
just put them in a box and leave them
outside
how many of you feel like you can check
your emotions at the door
before you go home at work to home when
you used to like go to work really
or when you're having a difficult
morning how many of you feel like i'm
just going to check my emotions
you know i'm going to leave them in my
car before i go into my office
it doesn't really work that way
because our brains don't operate we
can't pull out the emotion center
it just doesn't work that way when you
fail
at dealing with your feelings like many
of you say you have
what do you say to yourself let me ask
you that right now
be honest when you like really mess up
and
you say something that you regret or you
eat something you don't want to eat
or you you know
just engage in a behavior that you
didn't want to engage in because you
were upset
you yelled you screamed you ignored
what is it what is the dialogue that you
have with yourself i'm a bad person
i'm so stupid i screwed up
i'm so much of a fixed mindset right
that emotion judge right
and so one of the things that we try to
help people with is understand
a our emotions are ephemeral and b
that we are continuous learners and
that's more of a growth mindset around
it you know you fail it's like okay
i can apologize i can forgive i can
learn more and i can do better next time
and so that's basically getting at um
but these are hard skills oftentimes
emotions
are thought about as soft skills does
that resonate with you
people think of it as soft science or
soft skills which by the way makes me
crazy
since my whole career is as an emotion
scientist but nevertheless
that's the mindset um and i always joke
around
having been at young after 20 years has
anyone here at yale ever met someone who
was really smart but not emotionally
skilled
and you don't have to don't please don't
write that person's name
in the chat
so that leads us to bringing in
uh the skills so what are the underlying
skills
ru ler is the acronym that we use
recognizing emotions and self than
others
understanding the causes and
consequences
labeling emotions accurately having the
words knowing how and when to express
our feelings
having the strategies to regulate them
so self-awareness and other awareness
the ability to manage one's own emotions
the ability to help
others and managing theirs
so i did a talk a couple times ago for a
bunch of leaders and i asked them what's
the psychological difference between
stressed overwhelmed anxious
anyone want to take a stab at that
stressed
overwhelmed anxious
what's the difference
level of intensity they're the same
over under the judgment different way of
expressing
so what i'm trying to get at with our
work is the granularity
in terms of these differences so let me
share what i mean
stressed when you're stressed think
about it stress has to do with having a
lot of demands
but feeling like you just don't have the
resources to
to fulfill those demands
anxiety is this perception that there's
a lot of uncertainty around the future
like for example
vaccinations like some of us are waiting
we don't know when it's going to happen
there's uncertainty around that we don't
know about the
new strain of the virus is that going to
mess things up even more
that's what puts us in because that is
really it's not stress that's
actual anxiety overwhelm
is when you're overcome by your emotions
when you just feel like you have so much
in your plate you just can't breathe you
can't take it anymore
do people see the differences
does that make does that resonate with
you now the question is does it matter
does it matter would it matter for us to
be able to
be granular so i ask you why
why would that matter
seriously why does it matter
helps us manage better yeah there's a
saying that we have you have to name it
to detainment
you got to label it to regulate it and
think about if you're working with
someone who you're looking at them
in terms of their behavior so let's just
try this right now very quickly i'm
going to stop sharing
so imagine i come into your office i'm a
colleague of yours and i'm like i can't
take it anymore
okay been you're laughing at me thanks a
lot
all right so how am i feeling
how are you feeling if somebody comes in
how am i
so what happened just then and there did
you become the emotion scientist or the
emotion judge
and why did you become the judge
because you attributed emotion to me you
made an assumption that my behavior
meant something in terms of anger
frustration
whatever it might be and so it's a big
deal
in our work that in order to really know
how someone is feeling a you have to ask
them be
they have to tell you and that means
they have to be comfortable and feel
safe to do so
and we oftentimes grossly
make mistakes we make big mistakes when
we're judging someone's by their
behavior we have
stereotypes we have racial stereotypes
we have gender stereotypes we've got
i mean endless kinds of stereotypes
power stereotypes
and so when we when we
are observing behavior and we activate
stereotypic information
we're automatically biased in our
interpretation of others
does this resonate with everybody
yes but mark i had a quick uh question
if i may
if part of the problem is that we are
not able to even personally articulate
how
we are feeling as we saw i mean isn't
that like the first fundamental layer
of the problem that it is and so you've
got to have the language
in order to describe feelings because
that's the only way we know how to
communicate in this world
um and then you have to use that
language
understand the reasons for those
different feeling states like anger is
around this anger is around injustice
and disappointment is around my
expectations
then you've got to be able to notice it
in others you got to confirm that that's
how they're actually feeling
because you can't just if i stop i hate
you right i can't take it you think i'm
angry but it could be that i'm feeling
shame
i can't tell you in my childhood because
i had some serious bullying in my
childhood i would come home like angry
displaying
a lot of anger but i was feeling a lot
of shame and fear
and my parents constantly misperceived
me as being angry and then i got in
trouble when i got punished
and no one really supported me because i
was actually feeling
much deeper emotions like shame
so yes it's self-awareness building the
language understanding the strategies
and then
building relationships giving other
people their permission to feel
being that emotion scientists with them
and then
using that wisely right so good question
priya yeah and then part of this
masquerading
of you know don't we often do that even
as a way to cope
like we map something that is much like
you mentioned in your example
you match something you map something
that's much more intense that is shame
into something else which is anger
right so yeah doesn't that serve a
purpose for us
personally we do that intentionally
don't we
well i think we do it because as a
society we have deemed
that shame is a weak emotion
and so it's certainly not beneficial
right because
we're not going to get the supports that
we need to manage the true feeling if we
mask it with another
a one of work we got to do here priya
thank you very much yeah yeah
so i just wanted to share a couple more
slides one is
on a study that we did on emotional
intelligence and supervisor
and that's a typo um this is a study
where we looked at supervisor emotional
intelligence
high and low and then
different aspects of employees so skill
acquisition people feel like they're
more likely to acquire skills when they
have a supervisor who is higher in
emotional intelligence
much fewer turnover intentions much
greater job satisfaction
less burnout slightly more engagement
less fearful of speaking up um there was
actual more ethics
in a culture and a organization
with a supervisor who is higher in
emotional intelligence
so the last thing i'll share with you
today and then we can take some
questions is that
right now during the pandemic especially
people have been
you know asking us what are the
strategies to take care of ourselves to
take care of other people
and i'll just end by saying the first is
this concept of permission to feel
then we've got to help ourselves
regulate those feelings right we've got
to
maybe take that breath we also have to
do some
physical self-care like making sure that
we get enough sleep and
eat nutritious foods and move as much as
possible
we have the psychological self-care
taking time to be still
just doing some fun things social
connection we know
is a big one right now because we have a
pandemic of loneliness as well
so how do you remain connected in this
strange socially distant world
cognitive strategies the big one that we
focus on in our work is self-talk
how many of us have that negative
self-talk that automatic habitual way of
being a self-critic as opposed to
someone who's self-compassionate
and then routines in terms of setting
yourself up for success
so i thought maybe we can just do one
little exercise and maybe we can just
do a little breathing exercise to bring
ourselves into the present moment
let me just take a nice long inhale and
exhale
just bring ourselves in kind of digest
this information
and i'll just wrap up by sharing a few
last things
so ruler you heard in my intro is our
center's approach to teaching
social and emotional learning our goal
is to get away from piecemeal approaches
to more systemic models
and we have a fear of change and i just
want to say that one of the things that
we're trying to do in our world
and our work is get people away from the
quick fix mentality
so like here's your emotional times
workshop good luck
this is hard work i can tell you as
someone who's studied this and practiced
it for 20 years i'm still
25 years 30 years we got to move away
from like the one
size fits all thing like mindfulness has
become very popular now it's very
positive and useful but at the same time
some people don't benefit from that they
like other strategies
we have to think about this not from an
individual's perspective but from our
team
at work our entire department and we're
doing this at the child studies center
right now
we've had some challenges over the last
seven months
in multiple domains from people's
experiences
of racism to people feeling disconnected
and the only way to get through this is
to take a systemic approach it's not
about pulling someone out and giving
them some training
it really is about shifting the culture
and climate of the organization
and that means that we have to think
about this as a university it means we
have to think about this
in terms of the policies that govern our
country
so for example detaining children at
borders
probably is not good for their healthy
development so how do we inform policy
makers
right about the principles of healthy
emotional
development and so from the micro level
to the macro level
we have an app that we call the mood
meter app i'm very excited
one of our yale graduates his name is
ben silverman who is the founder of
pinterest is supporting our center and
the work and we're building on a new app
that's going to be like just incredible
so excited about it it'll have multiple
features this is our beta version
so if you're interested in plotting your
emotions over time
you can download that and let me
wrap up and then we'll take just a few
questions first
you got to evaluate your routines is is
your day working for you
try to be a preventionist surround
yourself with people who are calming
i can't tell you the power of the
presence of someone
who can bring your systemic
uh your so your nervous system levels
down your sympathetic arousal down
be aware of emotional contagion it works
for both pleasant and unpleasant
emotions so a stressed out parent is a
stressed at home a stressed out
boss is a stressed out workplace and so
we have to monitor those feelings
i say being uncle marvin that was the
person who was my hero in life
that presence of someone caring as i
mentioned think about
positive empathy in addition to
traditional empathy
positive empathy is just showing that
you care to someone else
um giving a compliment not a fake
compliment a real one
and you won't believe how far that will
go in terms of shifting their
biochemicals maybe consider your best
self
how do you want to be seen and talked
about and experienced
lastly as you know my work is about
emotion
i'm arguing and i'll argue this until
the end of time
that it starts with giving ourselves and
others the permission to be our full
feeling selves
there's no such thing as a bad emotion
people have deemed that anxiety is bad
and happiness is good
that's not a healthy way of thinking
about it all emotions are experienced as
their information
strive to be that emotion scientist not
the judge
remember it's about using our emotions
wisely
i think we have to appreciate that this
domain of
intelligence operates and functions
differently than traditional cognitive
abilities
it's much harder as we have seen in the
pandemic the levels of anxiety and
depression
have been higher than we've seen in
decades
which means that it's demonstrating that
it's hard to apply these skills
you know when the sand unfortunately
gets kicked in your face
and so we have to be mindful of that and
i think be more prevention focused as i
said earlier
maybe be the role model for your family
and your friends and your colleagues
be open to apologizing for giving and
repairing getting help that you might
need focus on systemic change and
i like to end in you know lofty ways
just because that's the way i operate
um i have a lot of hope for this work i
think that
we're finally as a nation taking
seriously
this other side of the report card still
we have another couple decades to
infuse it into the immune system of our
nation but
going back to the center's mission and
vision i think if we take seriously our
own
and others emotion skills we can build a
healthier and more equitable innovative
and compassionate society
and as i run around the world where i
used to anyway
and visiting schools for example here in
connecticut some of the most high
poverty areas i always ask myself
will this child have the the
opportunities
and learn the knowledge and the skills
to achieve their dreams
and i'm still not convinced you know
that we're there yet
and um so i'll end by saying
it's really our moral obligation to take
seriously our
emotional lives and the emotional lives
of others and i hope that this was
enjoyable and
let's take a couple minutes of questions
thank you
and if you want more information oops
let me just skip that it was a
x um that's the name of my book it's
permission to feel
my website is where you can go to learn
more about the book and also has links
to our center
and also to our school-based curriculum
so you can just go there and then
drive you to other resources and on that
note thank you
first question thank you so much thank
you so much mark
uh that was uh wonderful and ty
uh did you want to go ahead and uh
handle the questions so that people have
a chance to ask
that was absolutely fantastic with um
you know i wish we could have had you
for many more hours
for sort of more detailed sessions this
is
i think even this recognition that you
are offering us
is just uh so important right now
especially
thank you so much thank you i will uh
defer now to tai to handle the questions
sure thanks thank you chad thank you and
thank you mark
uh why would engagement with both a high
low
supervisor emotional intelligence be so
close on that graph
seems like a low emotional intelligence
supervisor would be discouraging
to be engaged that's a good question
and so i'm not 100 certain but what i
would say
is that it just might be that
for most people you know if they
um are
like they care or they're interested in
their actual workload and
whatever their job is um that it's less
effective it's slightly affected
but i think you know what's
and maybe people like to see themselves
as being engaged in their work
there's a little bit of method problem
problems there
but what i think is more interesting
is or not more interesting but i would
say relevant
is that engagement can also we found in
another study that engagement and
burnout are not inversely related
that there are people who are highly
engaged and also highly burnt out about
20 to 25 percent of the us workforce
reports that
what we find is that those people are
they they're they're doing their work
but deep inside they're really burnt and
they're looking for other jobs
and so that engagement can be masked
also with burnout
uh another question you so insightfully
talked about
the necessity of being able to properly
name
our emotions what to do then with
children especially young children
because we want to start them as parents
at a young age on the path to emotional
intelligence so
what are some of your recommendations
for parents and uh dealing with
young children yeah so i don't know
i'm embarrassing to plug my book but
that's a lot of my book
um is about it um but
just to give you like the basics is a
you got to be the role model
you know you have to be a parent who is
not going to be that toxically positive
parent that's
daddy is great or mommy's great
everything's fine right
a lot of people we just we we
we just desperately want our kids to be
happy all the time and so we fake how
we're feeling
and we try to convince our kids that
they're happier than they actually are
and i think that that's a disservice to
kids when they're having their feelings
the the best thing they do is to
validate those feelings and help them
label them properly
and then find out you know what they
need to support them in managing that
feeling
and then you'll have kids who have
greater well-being
they won't necessarily be happy all the
time but i think the goal for well-being
might be actually better than the goal
for happiness
and is that what your uncle marvin did
was that the side of the story
i said you know he and he was like gosh
you know you're being bullied you've had
terrible trauma in your life
like it's understandable let's talk
about it as opposed to
let's ignore it try to get rid of it wow
okay should we do one more
yep just going through the chat here
all participants are welcome to put
questions in the chat
a lot of compliments on how well
received your talk was appreciate that
thank you
okay that's cool susan well thank you
for sharing
glad to see that you're doing a ruler
well ty thank you yeah thank you so much
mark
for this wonderful hey rob just so you
know this rob who is on i'm
outing him but rob and i were roommates
uh are in college so that's 32 years ago
rob
yeah thanks for the reminder
[Laughter]
great job mark thanks rob good to see
you
thank you um thank you very much
take care everybody thanks so much thank
you